uh can you describe your recent match
against Gordon uh the ebi match okay so
ebi match on UFC Fight Pass it was a 20
minute match
and uh immediately uh no match starts I
pulled guard and then I stand up he
pulls guard and we have this uh kind of
like back and forth where he's trying to
dig for under hooks trying to get on top
of me and he can't really find success
uh and now and and then in the midst of
me trying to work my body lock pass uh
Gordon is able to underhook a leg and we
end up in a like entanglement and then
I'm able to transfer that leg and Tango
to a 50 50 position still like it's
still in the leg entanglement uh from
that 50 50 position I'm able to separate
his feet and and actually get a few pops
and he actually said I broke his foot in
that exchange with a toe hold the Toe
Hold yep and uh you know after after
that uh um we had a a bit more I was I
was just being uh working on top
positions trying to get my body lock
time runs out and we go to overtime and
over time can you hold on a second
actually what does it mean to break a
leg well I was very confused about okay
so is this like a expression or what do
you mean what are you broke which part
breaks in a Toe Hold okay so in a Toe
Hold uh there's a few different grades
of it like you could get a a few pops
and have some have some you know walking
issues
um and people consider that a break and
then you could break it fully and have
your foot be like a limp noodle you know
I think what what was that Achilles well
is the front of the Achilles or
something I mean probably the ligaments
I mean it's funny like a lot of people
say they broke something but like to me
you break bones you tear ligaments so I
would imagine you probably had a great
three tab
grade three how hard do you think is it
I always wondered that with um with like
a straight foot lock how hard is it to
break the shin or like the actual bones
versus the tear stuff depends how many
steroids they're on and obviously how
much Euro you're one of the few guys
that I have actually broken bones in
competition uh uh yeah have I oh yeah
couple yeah wow which bone did you break
spiral fracture of the fibula
Vinnie always used to say heel hooks
don't work leg locks don't work but
unfortunately age gets the best of all
of us I think he had some mileage on
those ligaments yeah and the bone I
guess yeah so it's actually what the the
bone yeah his ankle like disconnected
from the tibia and the fibula but the
fibula definitely snaps pretty bad
though that's fascinating